Im going away tomorrow.
You want me to take care of Poppy?
No. Poppy actually wanted me to take
care of you by getting rid of you.
He said I have to get rid of all my
friends.
There's. I mean, there's no way that
includes me. You understand that,
right? I agree with him.
Get rid of your friends.
He means Derek and Krills and Grills?
He meant those people.
Oh. The people you give opportunities
to who somehow blame you for them.
The people who have never started an
interesting conversation.
Anytime I've been around them.
I'm embarrassed.
You're right. Don't be embarrassed.
I get why it's fun to have
them around. When I was going through
my worst time, seeing your friends made
me feel like I was Abraham Lincoln.
Yeah, about that.
I actually also really wanted to talk
to you about something that's kind of
been bothering me.
I, you know.
Okay.
I am sorry.
That I basically lied to you about, my
drug problem and everything I was going
through. I knew I was hiding it from
you. It was on purpose.
I know you're like 29 now, but I still
feel some responsibility as an older
person to make sure you're okay.
You're always in crisis.
The idea of calling you for a crisis of
mine, maybe it actually would have
snapped you out of your own bullshit.
It would have helped.
Honestly. Yeah. I didn't think about
that. I'm  so obsessed with my own life
and problems.
Well, your life is fascinating.
Yeah, it is.
I mean, I don't know what it's like to
live it, but God d***, do we have fun
watching it. Yeah, it's a good time.
You know what it is? I'm not even first
of all, I. It does bother me a little
bit that everybody thinks it's my
fault.
And I understand why they do.
Of course. And you can too.
Of course.
I mean, we do one update feature
together and then my life completely
changes. There's theories online that
we swap souls.
I've read all of them. Yeah.
To the point where I was reading them,
I was like, did I?
Did this happen? Did this f******
happen?
We hug at the end and that's when people
say the souls switch.
Yes. And your soul came into me and
made me like a degenerate drug addict.
Yeah. Everyone thinks we Freaky
Friday'd.
We freaky Friday'd.
It makes a lot of sense.
I don't personally believe in the
theory, but it's well-researched and
footnoted.
Oh, you know what? It doesn't even
bother me that much. What really
bothers me is that you never.
You never shared.
You never shared the drugs.
What? You never shared.
We could have so much fun.
It was a dark, harrowing elevator shaft
of despair.
But you've never been cooler.
We were f****** five feet away in other
dressing rooms. And you were.
You were in there just wearing a suit.
Just f****** doing blow. That's
awesome, dude.
It was not awesome.
It looked awesome.
You didn't see it.
You're imagining it.
Okay, well, how do I know now that
you're good? And how will I know?
How will I know? How will I know that
I'll be good?
Well, first off, how will you know for
sure that I'm not on drugs?
Yeah, you won't.
Now in terms of you, Pete, I worry about
you to a level that I don't worry about
you. I have worried about you so much,
so deeply for so many late nights and
then gone on my computer to see that
you're courtside.
With Fill in the Blank.
Not just enjoying the game, laughing
your a** off with them.
Yeah, it's a fun time.
And this is the same night you're
texting me that you want to leave the
planet. Yeah.
How many times have I seen you just
fall off a building and land on your
feet or into the arms of a juicy sweats
model?
I don't know, John. I think I just.
I just want, like, a regular type life.
What the f*** is that?
Like, barbecues and baseball games and
s***?
Yeah.
I don't think it's made for you.
People don't want it from you, first
off. And second, I don't think you want
it. You've done absolutely nothing to
pursue it. We're in comedy, okay?
You got to be able to walk away from
anything in your life in 30 seconds
flat when you hear an offer around the
corner. That's why I got nothing tying
me down.
You have a kid.
Oh, yeah, Yeah.
I mean, there's so much I can't do.
It's great, though.
Look, here's what's going to happen.
You're going to go to this rehab,
you'll stay.
What's a usual stay? 28 days.
You'll stay about six, seven days.
Yeah. You'll either leave because they
ask you to or because.
I don't know. They won't let you smoke
in the hospital or something.
Yeah. Some disagreement.
You'll continue to be this bright,
talented light that seems in crisis to
everyone in the outside world.
We'll all take care of you.
And I'll continue to be this seemingly
okay guy all buttoned up.
But inside, having a f****** crisis all
the time.